there's this fight over the weekend that
we watch in
the most fire green room ever that is
just outside it's not really a green
room we kind of like made it that
but they like own the restaurant that's
upstairs from the comedy club and they
just have this like big terrace
like the terrace when you're doing three
shows and you're like in a green room
for eight hours
oh it can really wear on you but then
you go outside beautiful so we're
watching the fight island we also almost
died climbing up the stairs also
did the elevation you know it was crazy
islam or something i don't know exactly
how to pronounce the name
so um he fights this other guy
khabib's guy right yeah he's kind of
this guy here's the thing
that's really interesting and made me
realize what's going on
uh with the ufc and why they have a big
problem they potentially have a big
problem where their most dominant
fighters
uh are not interesting his he's
incredibly dominant he's
brilliant in his ability to like control
the fight uh
but it's wildly boring for the casual
i'm sure if you're a wrestling fan or a
grappling fan like seeing this guy's
like
use of his weight and like movement of
his hips and his ability to maintain
control is really exciting you know
like watching a chess match or something
like that for someone who's really into
chess is exciting but for someone who's
never played is like the [ __ ] is this
boring ass game right
so the people that are the highest
uh money-making fighters in the ufc
right are not guys who have these like
amazing records right you're looking at
connor
uh nate diaz and i think jorge mazda all
guys who have lost
right their last fight uh jorge masridal
and nate diaz if you looked at their
records
are journeymen essentially conor is
maybe the most engaging sports figure
of the last uh i don't know 25 years it
is unbelievable what this guy can do
they fight in exciting ways strikers
going for knockouts
big time fights they can promote the
[ __ ] out of a fight
my concern for the ufc and for dana
white is what is he to do with a guy
who is not very exciting in the promo or
build-up of the fight
you know uh the people in khabib camp
are about like respect
and uh not really ruffling feathers not
saying anything that could be
disrespectful or even hurtful to an
opponent uh just coming out there and
getting it done
well this isn't the olympics yeah this
is the entertainment business yeah
we're selling pay-per-views selling
[ __ ] pay-per-views you're not
engaging in the pre-fight you're not
engaging in the post fight
during the fight it's boring as [ __ ]
because you're just on top of the guy
the whole time
is dana white terrified that this is
gonna be the next guy who dominates the
division
i think he's okay because he's got
enough other people
and i think the sport has been growing
and agree with khabib and there will be
somebody who will provoke this
[ __ ]
somebody gonna come around you get
another get another connor you got izzy
here he gonna like
you're still gonna make your money for
dana white and then you can point to
this guy and call him the technician or
whatever
not everybody has to be izzy connor nate
diaz
you got those guys to carry and then you
got these other guys to say oh look how
technically superior he is
i think that's what i'm thinking as i'm
hearing this out loud like
you need a guy like that you need a guy
like khabib you need a guy like this to
be like oh
look how good and dominant he is and
then you need the other guys
like mosvidal to be like man that guy's
just fun huh let's just watch this well
otherwise it's just a spectacle
it made me look at this and go like holy
[ __ ] khabib really needed connor
yes i don't think anybody gave a [ __ ]
about khabib no without conor
and he is the most dominant person
that's ever fought in the sport yeah but
conor comes around that rivalry
really props up khabib and khabib gets
to profit off of that rivalry yeah right
like all the antics and [ __ ] that
happens
around the conner khabib fight yeah
i mean next level yeah so it's just like
is khabib as financially viable
as he is now without conor i don't think
so like we almost like
and also he's kind of a he's kind of
charismatic he's he understands
entertainment he's more so than this
other dude yeah but like
i'm i kind of really built up the
mystique of khabib 9
now i don't think khabib is really
driven by money from what it seems yeah
he loves to fight and he'll take money
but he doesn't really seem that driven
by it yeah
so i don't want to act like he's
hypocritical or whatever but like
for sure i didn't know about khabib
until kana yeah and i'm a very much a
casual
yeah so i guess what i'm what i'm saying
is like
if these guys yeah these guys meaning
like the dagestani wrestler types
right are gonna be dominant in the ufc
you need to make sure that you're
pairing them yes with incredibly
charismatic and entertaining fighters
even if they beat them that they can
push and promote the fight you know it
would be great
dylan donnis yeah if he's if his knee is
right
he'll promote the [ __ ] out of that fight
but you need that you need that
you need that because they're not going
to promote and they're not going to make
it interesting i have no interest in
watching that guy fight again
he did nothing for me if there's a fight
with him next week and it's a
pay-per-view i'm not paying i don't care
unless the other guy on that card
you